coming up so poor is why I realized
education is abord my parents came from
the old country where my father only had
a second grade education my mom had a
kindergarten so it was never really
embedded in us the education especially
for a girl was that important it was
more about survival
my mom was arranged marriage when she
was young so already in her head I was
gonna be arranged at the age of 16 get
marry and who do I marry another person
who owns a Chinese restaurant and sure
enough at the age of 16 I had met my
future husband who owned a restaurant in
Long Island I told my mom and dad no way
I want to go to college and it never
even dawned on them that Heather should
go to college we came to a crossroad
with the lease of the restaurant was up
it was at the time all my brothers stood
up for me and said mom and dad I think
let's give up the restaurant we all got
to do what we got to do and then Heather
go to college it was hard because I
didn't have anybody to help me I only
applied to three school I don't apply to
Rutgers Cornell and like a safety school
I wrote my Cornell undergrad and pencil
my application I didn't even know to
apply in Penn
I got into Rutgers when I got there I
didn't know about financial aid so how
did I pay for my first year of college
all my savings for working it since I
was 7 years old in a Chinese restaurant
it was then that I met my college
roommates and I said you paid you could
get financial aid then people start
helping me when I was in Taiwan when I
was 17 and visiting there was an
earthquake
I saw the air conditioner fell on
somebody's head I just you know tilted
his head so they need to breathe and I
was screaming for help and it was then
that I I said I wanted to help people
my mom once says I wish Heather would
have been a boy then I could brag about
her
yeah even throughout what I want to go
to grad school my mom was still saying
why just get married have kids that's
why you supposed to be doing whereas my
dad finally dhananand like oh wow she
actually could be doing something and
gave me $10,000 to go to grad school
my brother's daughter I'm really proud
of her
she went to UPenn I give dittos to her
she's the first one to graduate Ivy
League in a family oh but it's all
because of me
when she was 12 I was the one that said
no one ever
mentor me but from day one every time
when you're gonna go to college you're
gonna go to college you're going to
college every any help I'll pay for it
yada yada yada yada so that give them
the the confidence and the support that
they need they can have
[Music]
they're quite amazed on how our life
even my brother figures whatever
happened to me is also you know have us
to them so they're really proud and of
course having my undergrad open the door
for me to go to grad school and we
should let me to become the physician
assistant that I am today if you want to
go to college you should you should go
to college go for it